sorry sorry for the
delay
call the uh executive
session uh to
order and I'd ask uh Stan for salute the
flag yes thank you please join with me
in a pledge to our flag I pledge Alle to
the flag of the United States of America
to the repu for which it stands one
nation God indivisible liy and justice
for
all all
right all
right first off uh I'm going
to make a few announcements on the
changes uh and adjustments to the
uh executive
session uh House
Bill uh
21 which is at the end of the the uh
session relative to C creating certain
Wetland permit exemptions after a
natural
disaster or flooding event we will be
having a uh a u work session on I've
decided that we should we need a we
could not make meet a consensus uh I'd
like to have a there's a there's should
be able to have a work session on this
and I'll we schedule that for next
week uh
there is uh it probably be scheduled we
have a I think there's a space of 9:00
is available I'm not mistaken yes sir so
uh might as well use at 9:00 uh for next
uh this same time or nine o'clock next
week uh and will it'll be it'll be in
the
calendar so I will not be hearing the
rest of uh or the
hearing uh executing that bill
today okay also
uh go to house will start at uh on House
Bill 1046
FN uh you have a a representative rung
you have a a an amendment you wish to
bring forward a friendly Amendment to
the bill yes I do um representative
Darby and I um well representative Derby
worked on an amendment to close that
little issue of timing of the boat owner
um he shared it with uh Captain dun
lovey who approved it the amendment is
at upstairs but the copy machine is
being serviced and they expect it will
be repaired very very soon and so if you
don't mind Mr chair would if we could
just skip this for a few minutes as soon
as I get the email from them that the
copies have been made I'll run up and
get
it I did email the amendment to
everybody but I'm not sure people can
read it as clearly on their phone or
computer as having the hard copy when
did you email just now uh yeah about a
few minutes ago
okay yeah I still don't have 10 after 10
what's the time frame um she told me
five minutes and that was probably 10
minutes ago that the machine would be
fixed changing
what does he just uh just uh you explain
to yeah could I defer to representative
Darby he's the one that drafted the
amendment well first of all let me just
say
representative uh late amendments are
not looked
upon with happiness by the chairman so I
know I'm very sorry Mr chair I will
bring apple pie next week and leave it
in the committee room
yeah yeah my grandmother's recipe bring
the
flag I could you speak to what the
amendment is uh as amendment is for and
then I'll I will uh yeah yes AB postpone
this thank you Mr chair and I do
apologize I know I recognize how rude it
was to Spring this at the last minute um
it was a question that I asked during
um during the hearing um and that we
that was discussed so um as as you
recall um the currently when you
involved in an accident you have to
exchange information with um the
operator the other um bow owner um you
have to or or the property that you
damaged if you can't contact them then
you have to provide it to um Marine
Patrol the second thing is within 15
days you have to um uh you have to file
a report with the Department of Safety
um if the um if the operator of the boat
um the the the bill stated if the
operator of the report refuses to or is
unable to file the report then it has to
um then the owner of the boat has to uh
file the report um on their behalf what
that leaves is that since they didn't
have to file it for 15 days there's a
15-day delay between um when up to a
15-day delay between when the accident
happened and when the the um the report
actually has to be filed so this uh
Amendment adds four words that says if
the um if the operator uh refuses to or
cannot file the report or provide
required information It's that or
provide required information um which
closes the the for the 15-day um
window
okay Captain before I open on the
hearing on this captain
you have you had a chance to review
this yes
sir thank you yes sir I have and uh
we're fine with that it is appropriate
thank you all right I'll I'll put I'll
I'll move uh I will I I'm not moving
anything I I move I am uh not starting
then with 10 10:46 and I'll bring it up
a little bit later once the once the
text the amendment arrives and uh we
will look at it from we will then we
will then with then look at it uh do we
then exec it all right uh
Sor I will open the executive session on
House Bill
representative
dley I'd like to move that itl 14
23 you like to speak to
your I do I have a second I'll second
that Mr Chair seconded by representative
harb like to speak to your motion thank
you Mr chair uh based on what we've
heard and uh understand from this
particular bill is the state uh does not
see the need for this additional um
feature would you like to speak to your
a
second believe the representative
covered my comments thank you
representative uh rung for
for to
speak thank you Mr chair I'm not sure if
the committee saw this in their email
but it is a hard copy is being passed
around it was an
amendment um it's
20242 3 6h but it was prepared by the
prime sponsor representative Kaplan but
it does a great job of addressing the
issues that came forth in the public
hearing it limits this mapping to just
State Forest um it has a de definite
timeline which addresses some of the
costs um so Mr chair if I could indulge
you to ask the committee to spend a
minute just looking on this I think it
would address a lot of the issues that
um L led to the itl motion
right on the
floor we
uh we if the oh if I if the itl Was
Defeated guess we would look at that but
I would I would allow I would allow for
a a minute for folks to read the uh
Amendment see if it
uh
we have all completed reading the
amendment anyone needs any more time to
read
it
okay there any
uh is there any more uh discussion on
the uh on the motion of itl
seeing none but please call the
all Yes
um I just uh did you want to introduce
our uh two substitute members uh
representative Harvey and representative
Fox would you like
to introduce
our members who replacing who yes um
thank you Mr chair so thank you for
coming we have drew Fox that is here for
um representative love it and we have uh
Kathy Harvey who's here for aan Kelly
thank you for joining us
today thank you okay uh representative
harb
yes uh representative
Horan oops I'm sorry um representative
Goulds yes
clerk votes yes representative Healey
yes representative wolf
yes representative MCU yes
representative Donnelly yes
representative D yes representative Vale
yes representative rung
no representative
Harvey
yes oh
okay
um representative
Simpson
no uh representative Baldwin
yes uh representative Darby
no okay representative Hoy
no representative
lontine
yes representative
Fox
Ryan
no representative Ren
Zulu yes okay that is 15 y five Nays
motion
passes representative Donal you write
the
report be delighted thank you is will
there be a Minority
Report yes Mr chair there will be a
Minority
Report that
closes House Bill
1423 uh now open on House
Bill
uh
there okay and a motion the while the
chair recognizes representative wolf for
motion I move out to pass on
1429 14
1429 is there a
second we have Amendment yes there is a
but that I will I'll I'm G I will call
for an
amendment we have a representative Derby
is the second y representative Darby has
as a second it did you say did you
second it okay
okay I know there there is an amendment
to that
bill
we have actually two two amendments to
that
bill
uh I think there's there is
a it's a little tricky when you have two
amendments because uh probably ought to
since they're
representative uh rep a bill from
representative Maser
is uh the uh so you are you you want you
will I will excuse oh yes that's right
and we do want to get it before the
before the board uh representative mchu
for for a motion thank you Mr chairman
I'll move uh Amendment
224-227 sent out yesterday by uh
Representatives Alexander and merer I
believe I think it came from
representative Alexander's email can you
um go slow can I can I have the numbers
again please uh it's 2024
0227 H that's the amendment to House
Bill
1429 it was uh out by email wait a
minute
yesterday you have uh representative Ma
you have there was
a I I have I have a
09h 10 one from
last Mr Mr chair the initial amendment I
think you're looking at which is 0109 H
that was presented at the public hearing
but it has since been there's a more
recent amendment that came from
representative Maser that is the 0227 H
H yes I have I do have that have
that huh it it's in your email just like
the one you just sent out five minutes
ago
yep it went to the it went to the
committee email I mean that's how I got
it do do you have any additional copies
of that Amendment with
you
well I I I know you it I know it went
out to uh the rr&d committee but you
should have the amendment as hard
copy with you
always when you come
to yeah so Mr chairman I'm happy to
speak to
it all right uh it it was it went out to
the whole committee yesterday at uh 4:35
and along also went out to the
co-sponsors uh it's 0 227h and it it it
takes into account the feedback from the
municipal Association and
Dees uh and it's enabling legislation it
is an all after the enacting Clause I
believe let me just bring it back up um
yeah it's all after the enacting Clause
so it takes into account their feedback
it enables towns should they choose and
only if they vote Yes on two issues one
is wanting to transfer it and also
wanting to uh fund it and if either
question fails by the local governing
body whatever that may be um then the
offer to transfer the dam would be
rejected so both tests have to pass and
it's enabling legislation to allow
localities to control and perhaps
improve their own infrastructure if they
want
to and that was the feedback we got and
that's what this amendment
does representative Derby thank you Mr
chair with um with one minor
clarification that if it if it fails the
municipality the department um may offer
it to an association of land owners or
any interested parties registered as a
public entity um so there is there is an
an option and um the amendment also
uh address the concern that I have about
um about how to vet those um non-public
and or those um those private uh
landowner associations that um before
the uh before the loan is offered they
can be vetted
financially representative M thank you
Mr chairman um one last thing I forgot
to mention is it does establish that
Loan Fund but funds it at at a dollar uh
so this bill presumably will go to
finance and they'll have a look at it
and might get considered the next budget
year or who knows uh but there isn't a a
funding beyond that that dollar to to
make loans so the municipality would
have to figure out basically how to how
to fund it if they wanted to do whatever
their governing body chooses they
do any other any other question I well
let me let me first off um I have a
concern
that not everybody has a copy of
this this in front of them
uh is is these copy machines still still
broken upstairs
yeah if you every what you could you
could take my copy
and or yeah just pass it
down
uh lee why not
please all
right all right I'm I I will be uh I'll
I'll be recessing this for a couple of
minutes while we we wait uh one one
additional thing we're going to run into
there is another memo
another there's
a
hello there's another memo there there's
I received a memo that there's
another uh
amendment that also wants to be uh to
this bill however it was built around
the
original U the the bill as originally
put forth we will take that up unless
you you wish to remove that
representative
lante um no well it was built around the
amendment but the paragraph that was
affected is the same in all versions of
the amendment okay of the bill and the
amendment okay well that's the reason I
called the the the uh the big Amendment
first was because I was concerned that
yes uh if we had if if we put your
amendment in it or if if your amendment
was successful and the Second Amendment
the big Amendment came in it would wipe
that
out thank you Mr chairman just to to
clarify parliamentary wise the motion on
the floor is ought to pass as amended
with amended 0227 yes if if that passes
it would then potentially be open to
further Amendment or not yes it would
okay yeah so do we need to take action
on the motion on the floor uh yes we
will and that's why I'm going to re I'm
going to recess for or I'm I'm I'm
trying to delay enough so that she can
have the motion have the amendment here
for everyone to read to go to look
at question yeah Mr chair um my
understanding is that the amendment was
moved but not OTP yet uh yeah the
amendment was movp was moved oh okay and
and the amendment was was was uh I
called for an amendment after after
that right yes I did that yes uh yeah
yeah we didn't vote on the uh first one
we have we have right you don't vote on
the first one you have the all the
Amendments done then you vote on the Au
to passes Amendment
the uh I'm not
well why don't I I will yeah I will move
to the next one I will just uh
recess uh this is
1029 1429 excuse me recess
1429 uh and take it if to a to a t to a
uh to the later part of the
agenda okay House Bill
relative uh to environmental surity
bonds and for businesses that pose a
significant risk to the state's natural
resources
uh
chair recognizes representative lontine
for a motion
I make a motion to
itl do I have a
second a second Mr
chair you like to speak on your motion
yes I
would um well I really appreciate the
attent of this bill to make polluters um
pay um I there were a lot of problems
with the bill um first it was really
overly broad um referring to um anybody
who works in an industry that may
pollute the soil water um or air might
be subject to the shity bond and it
seemed that um in order for this the
bond to be truly a deterrent from
pollution it would have to be enormous
not to be written off as an upfront
business expense that the industry may
be willing to pay and then go on
polluting for 30 years making enormous
profits um it seems that bonds work
better to have an industry do something
good like the last house my husband and
I built we had a bond to plant some
trees um which we did and then we were
paid
back um but ultimately seems like the
best way to pre is to prevent the
pollution in the first place rather than
to put out a bond to make the polluters
pay to clean it up
afterwards so that is my perspective
that we need to instead of doing the
bond make sure we have adequate
regulation of the industries to PR
prevent the pollution
like to speak to you a
second um thank you Mr chair uh
representative lontine answered um posed
my anyone else wish to speak to to the
motion thank you the clerk
this the one you gave us a few minutes
ago no that one's mine which is an
amendment which one this
for yeah please call though just going
to let her sit down
yep okay thank you Mr chair and and
representative harb
yes representative GS representative
Horgan don't know this it is a motion of
itl on House Bill
1477 uh representative forgan votes yes
the clerk votes yes representative
Healey
yes representative wolf yes
representative McHugh yes representative
Donnelly yes representative Dunn yes
representative veale yes representative
rung yes representative Harvey yes
representative Simpson yes
representative Baldwin yes
representative Darby yes representative
hoit this is not is
absent representative L
montine yes representative Fox yes
representative Ryan Yes representative
rulu
yes than you that is 19 yay z uh Ys 19
to zero
passes move
consent
okay we'll go uh we'll move back to
house bill
uh
29 uh we were everyone now does everyone
have a copy of
uh of the
amendment
227 okay this is this is this is another
this is yeah I have
cop anybody cop
yes yes Mr chair I did distribute the
amendment that I was waiting for about
the coping machine that that but that
would be for um uh Amendment on
1046 yeah unfortunately we're right in
the middle of
1429 and that's going to get lost
so well if we're we're in a state of
confusion but that's all okay all right
uh and we were in the we were in the uh
dis in a discussion
on uh Amendment
H uh I'll just start back uh
representative is there anything that
you might want to say
any on
the thank you Mr chairman so the mo the
motion I've made is that the committee
that the committee
adopt Amendment 20240 227h for House
Bill 1429 now everybody has a hard copy
was emailed yesterday he's a hard copy
now and it was this was the discussion
it made a couple of points that it was
enabling uh that it requires the test to
the governmental body to accept to to
agree to accept it and fund it and there
as representative Derby pointed out
there's some alternate mechanisms of
funding uh as well and the Loan Fund is
funded at at a dollar so essentially un
unfunded at that point if if you and
that would only come into play if the
municipality wanted a loan right or need
needed to apply for a loan so at some
future date that could be funded by
Finance or another
legislature or what have you okay is
there any uh any questions uh or any
comments on
the on the
amendment seeing none on on
Amendment
H the F please call the
rooll on the amendment ought to pass on
the
amendment representative harb
yes representative GS
representative Horgan clerk votes yes
representative Healey yes representative
wolf yes representative MCU yes
representative donelly yes
representative Don yes representative
Vil yes representative run yes
representative Harvey yes representative
Simpson yes representative Baldwin yes
representative Darby yes
representative Hoy is
absent representative lontine yes
representative Fox
yes representative Ryan yes and
representative
Rula yes as 19 yay zero Nays motion
passes
the motion on the floor is sought to
pass as amended by that Amendment or
open a further Amendment yeah yes but
first i'm looking at the further
Amendment the further Amendment
unfortunately it came in based
on it's it has amend the bill by
replacing all after the enacting Clause
so what we just did would be erased by
this amendment we be back to the
beginning there could I speak to that
for a moment uh yes I don't if we before
we before I accept the
amendment if we say because my amendment
was based on the original amendment by
representative Mur which was changed
just last night that if we just say that
my amendment is based on the amendment
just
adopted my amendment is only one line I
I realize but the only the only thing
that I had received up until this point
was not what you what has been presented
here it was only thing I received
was the after line 17
after Downstream and add other words
adding that section I thought that would
be the
amendment I did too all I asked OS was
to add that one line I didn't realize
they were going to
say replace the whole thing because I
did only change one
line I I realized
but where is
the where is I
uh
committee uh committee
researcher we
can't if we adopt this
amendment we lose the other
Amendment first huh no it has not it has
not been moved okay I'm just looking at
what we're seeing I'm in a situation
where this is a this amendment wipes out
the First Amendment we just voted which
is changes several
things
uh so what I have to do we'd have to do
is I can allow you to uh get back to OS
as quickly as possible and get another
amendment or get the amendment such that
it does not
interfere or or like like it was
originally put in to just mentioning the
spot where it would go in and and
uh then we would that we would then
continue with this the uh the hearing on
this on on this I'd have to postpone the
hearing till later on in the day ex the
executive
session um would it be possible for me
to suggest an amendment should it pass
and go to the Senate that I amended at
that stage well definitely you could
also sub I don't want to hold everything
up you could also uh you could also oh
there's a spider on
it I gave it
to uh you can do it as a floor
Amendment and you could do it as a yeah
you could do it as a floor Amendment
Finance or in finance it would be
there okay so you wish to withdraw it
yes thank you thank you very
much that being said
on I guess the motion is ought to pass
as amended as
amended and
ute representative wolf who made the
original a to pass a to pass we like to
speak on ought to pass as amended on
1429 on
I move out to pass as
amended okay you've
already and would you like is there a
second the pass I'll
second second would you like to speak on
it I think we've heard enough on this
bill so far would you like to speak on
your second thank you Mr chairman so the
bill is now been replaced by the
amendment that we just passed so we're
effectively now voting hun a new bill
which is the amendment 0227 H yep the
one we just passed
okay
on on
0429 as
amended the court please call the
RO okay it's um on House Bill
1429 yep 1429 14 1429 as
amended okay representative harb yes
representative G yes representative
Horgan yes clerk votes yes
representative Healey yes representative
wolf yes representative MCU
yes representative Donnelly yes
representative dun yes representative
Vale yes representative Rong yes
representative Harvey yes representative
Simpson yes representative Baldwin yes
representative Derby
yes HS not here uh representative
lontine yes representative Fox yes
representative Ryan yes and the chair
yes that is 19 y zero Nays motion
passes Mo consent cons set
Gall don't
moved cons
set and let's go on excuse me um point
of order Mr chair yes is this bill going
to finance yes it is um I don't think it
can go on consent can it
uh yeah but it's got a dollar okay I
think if it's more I think if it's more
than a certain okay I just want to bring
it up because yeah it always comes up oh
yeah it always comes up and
and nobody says
anything all
right on
04 next
is
04045 HBA
1045 relative to requiring a Powerbolt
operator to wear an engine cut off
switch while operating certain power
bolts traveling over Headway
speed they're recognized as
representative done for a motion
I make a motion ought to
pass motion is ought to pass is there a
second second by representative rung
would you like to speak to your
motion yes I think this is a safety
issue and something that um we should
have so I think it's it'll prevent the
boats from going in circles and we
should we should do
this would you like to speak to your a
second um I'll just say that the
testimony given by captain Levy was very
powerful about the need for this and um
also just want to note that I'm a
co-sponsor on this Bill thank
you anyone anyone else wish to speak on
the
motion oh representative
Veil thank you um I just wanted to
mention that I appreciate the hard work
on this bill and it will save lives and
that's what we're doing here is trying
to save lives and I imagine that the
circumstances where this will be helpful
will be be helpful for everyone involved
in public safety thank
you representative representative Darby
for a uh to speak on the motion thank
you Mr chair this is uh definitely an
important bill um and I think that it
will um help to save lives and help to
keep people safe um as I expressed
during my questions um I I do have one
very small concern um with the bill
which has to do with um people trolling
um above what I uh as I interpret the
language Headway speed meaning the um
the speed where no wake is produced
people troll up to three and a half
miles an hour which um can and often
does produce a small wake that same
Headway speed language is used in um uh
in no wake zones and you wouldn't be
allowed to go um produce that size wake
in a no wake zone as um Captain Dunley
um testified um that's not the intent of
this bill um and I think this bill
should pass however I um if I were to
vote against it it would be just to
express my concern that that Clause
should be added to um the language um so
that it could be considered by the
Senate thank
you
anyone else anyone else wish to uh speak
on the
motion see no one okay please call the
rooll yes representative harb on Bill
House Bill 1045 aop pass
yes representative G yes representative
Horgan yes cler votes yes representative
Healey yes representative wolf yes
representative MCU yes representative
Donnelly yes representative Dunn yes
representative
Vale
yes representative rung yes
representative Harvey yes representative
Simpson yes representative Baldwin yes
representative Derby
no representative hoit
yes representative L montine yes
representative love uh Fox
yes representative
Ryan yes and
chair
yes that is 19 to one motion passes
set you want to write a Minority Report
so can't be on
consent so there is a a Minority Report
representative
Derby and you can those I would like the
reports by Friday if possible because
they're they're trying to fill up
a fill up a session you need reports all
right okay
okay on U how we'll open this open the
uh executive session on House Bill
1049 relative to the prohibition of
overnight Moorings of house boats
representative bail for a
motion thank you Mr chair I make a
motion of itl on this
bill is there a
second I'll second it
who was
that done okay I'll second
okay you wish to speak on your motion
yes I do Mr chair thank you um so I just
had a couple of concerns with this bill
um and I don't want
to make a flat out
um ban
or just go ahead and pass a bill that
releases any um accountability between
boat owners and so when I thought about
this I thought you know how do private
property owners receive uh what do they
do how is it determined who has the
right of
way when it comes to leaving their docks
and the other thing was that um we don't
have a really clear
definition of the toileting facilities
on these boats so um at this point point
I think the emails were really
compelling um and we're really concerned
about the health of the laks so I would
like to see um something that is more of
a compromise um than this bill puts
forth thank you Mr chair for the
opportunity to
speak representative D wish to speak on
your second yeah I'll just say this
committee received over 200 emails
against this and my constituent spoke
loud and clear that they did not want
this
so representative L montin
for um should speak yes I I will vote
for the itl but I did want to speak to
the bill because I I had some concerns
about the bill the bill well statute now
still allows overnight Moorings and
houseboats on these bodies of water but
only if associated with property on the
shore either by that owner or by a
friend of theirs with
permission and the water does belong to
everybody I was disturbed by some of the
language in the email
suggesting that I don't want house boats
in front of my property as if they own
the water as well and they
don't my other issue is that I I once
lived on a house boat myself for one
winter on an inland waterway in the city
of Boston and for three Summers where I
was a seasonal worker and it was
affordable housing for me and we have a
housing problem in New Hampshire
especially in the in the Lakes region in
the Summer where they need workers who
can't find a place to live and work for
the season but I did feel the bill
didn't
really address the many concerns we
would have about
sanitation but most of the complaints
about
noise are happening already with party
boats this has nothing to do with party
boats going around the lake at night so
I hope that this bill can come back with
perhaps a very complicated way that we
can look at protecting water quality and
also providing opportunities for
seasonal
housing um
so that's I just wanted to say that
about
it anyone else wish to speak on the
bill seeing
none The Click please call the
rooll yes um by the way a yes vote is
for the motion of
itl the no vote would be against the it
okay um on the motion of itl on House
Bill 1049 representative harb
yes representative G yes representative
Horgan yes clerk votes yes
representative Healey yes representative
wolf yes representative McHugh no
representative Donell
yes representative dun yes
representative Veil yes representative
rung yes representative Harvey yes
representative
Simpson yes representative Baldwin yes
representative Derby yes representative
hoit yes representative lontine yes
representative Fox yes representative
Ryan yes and chair
no that is 18 gays and and two Nays
motion
passes and I I want I will not put this
on consent I will uh allow it to go to
the floor for for debate if need if
minority no no no Minority
Report at the
uh so the bill the bill is uh yeah
it uh let's see I think we have already
uh dispensed with
1121 let's go back
to
1046 excuse me 11 1103 oh 11:03 oh that
oh I would PL I'm going to worry about
that one
on House Bill 1103 relative to the
revised penalties for Shoreland
protection yes representative run for a
motion thank you Mr chair I move um
ought to pass on House Bill
1103 I have a
second I'll second who was
that no she we'll go with Darby Derby
was
first you pick which much you like to
say I want my colleague from maram
representative make it a mar an all
marac
Bill second by rep representative Healey
oh you wish to speak to your motion yes
Mr chair thank you very much um as was
explained during the public hearing what
this bill does is it allows the
Department of Environmental Services to
enforce violations of the shoreline
protection water quality act um
presently the statute really complicates
their ability to enforce because it
requires them to demonstrate that
there's been damage to a water body and
many times that damage may take years
it's cumulative with other actions so um
it right now the only change this makes
the statute is it maintains the language
it says persons violating the provisions
of this chapter
shall be subject to the following and it
maintains all the current enforcement
actions but it deletes the language that
says and damaging the public water way
who after notification by the department
failed to make a good faith effort at
remediation and
restoration that that language um that
this bill is proposing to eliminate has
really complicated the process of
enforcement because it puts the burden
on the state to determine what good
faith means um in addition to the issue
I brought up about um assessing damage
to a water body so this has the support
um I think you know when we heard
testimony um from Darlene forest from
the Department of Environmental Services
she explained some situations where
they've been handcuffed and I did
believe I do believe she sent an email
out within the last couple days um I
think it was to you representative
Harvey bolo um asked for other examples
she sent four other examples which
really documents the need to have this
bill pass thank
you yours to speak dear
second I think she covered it pretty
well um I just wanted to add that there
some of the companies or entities that
have uh uh done this numerous times that
uh that was brought up also
so anyone else wish to speak to the bill
representative
thank you Mr chair um I I believe this
is a critical bill and it's really
important and some of the egregious
violations that we were presented with
make it really a much more important
bill and um these violations can now be
pursued and the owners and violators can
be held accountable thank you for
bringing this
forth representative Darby for a thank
you Mr chair just expanding on
representative Run's remarks very
briefly um we heard that uh in order for
uh Dees to enforce the current statute
they have to prove damage the entire
water body which is impossible um they
they said it is impossible on water
bodies the size of Lake sanap or lake
winaki in addition we heard and uh
examples were provided of how Department
of Environmental Services wants to work
with property owners in order to um
mitigate they're not looking to find
people except when the those um those
parties are not willing to um to abide
abide by the um Shoreline protection act
so this is this is a critical
enforcement uh tool um but would only be
used you know in egregious uh manners
thank
you anyone else seeing no
one will the clerk please call the rooll
yes on house Bill
1103 motion of a to pass representative
harp
yes representative G yes representative
Horgan yes CL votes yes representative
Healey yes representative wolf yes
representative McHugh
yes representative Donnelly yes
representative Dunn yes representative
Vil yes representative rang yes
representative Harvey yes representative
Simpson yes representative Baldwin yes
representative Derby yes representative
ho yes representative lontine
yes representative Fox
yes representative Ryan yes and the
chair
yes that is 20 yays zero Nays motion
passes
for
consent takes care of 1103 we got go
back to house
bill
FN uh chair recognizes representative
Healey for a
motion any motion of ought to pass on
1046 and do I have a
second second by representative rung
there is it's uh 1046 is on the floor
subject to Amendment we have an
amendment from representative
Darby thank you Mr chair I'd like to
make a motion um to um um for an
amendment amendment number
2024 uh
H anyone for a second second by
representative rung representative Derby
do you wish to speak to your
motion that that should have yeah that
went around did it go around yes yes you
you got it down there I
got
okay I told you this what
happened when you get too many pieces of
paper passing along you can have you got
everybody got Amendment got it
now you
uh okay you all have it just to speak to
your Amendment repres yes thank you Mr
chair um this amendment adds four words
on line 20 the last four words of line
20 or provide required information this
closes um what I perceive as a loophole
in uh the original Bill where the um
owner of the vessel doesn't have to um
provide a report until after the 15-day
uh uh period for reporting the accident
um this would say this would indicate
that if the operator of the vessel um
did not or was not able to provide the
information either providing it to the
um operator of the other vessel or the
property that was damaged or reporting
it to Marine Patrol then the um then the
owner of the vessel would need to
provide that as soon as they were U made
aware of the situ of the
incident you wish to speak to the uh
your second on the amendment yes thank
you Mr chair no I I want to thank
representative Darby for catching that
loophole and closing it because that
would be a significant issue for Marine
Patrol um for the boat owner to be to
recognize it but milk out the 15 days
before filing the report so thank you
representative
Darby can we
and uh Captain Don Levy you uh you
already made your statement uh that you
were you're Co you're copesthetic with
this
you had to haven't heard that word in 40
years I
know being the is there anyone else who
wishes to speak uh to the to this
amendment or as a question if not on the
amendment will the clerk please call
pardon I'd like to just speak after the
vote's taken up yep that's
okay um the amendment on the amendment
2025 2 2 H for House Bill 1046 represent
of harb yep yes representative G yes
representative Horgan yes CL votes yes
representative key yes representative
wolf
yes representative muu yes
representative Donnelly yes
representative Dunn yes representative
Vale yes representative run yes
representative Harvey yes representative
Simpson yes representative Baldwin
yes representative Darby yes
representative Hoy yes representative
lontine yes representative Fox yes
representative Ryan yes
and the
chair yes that's 20 to zero motion
passes motion passes does it
on
consent oh I'm sorry
so been a long day
already on the on a motion of ought to
pass as
amended there the there any
representative he making M Mo yeah
representative Healey made the motion
you wish to speak on
it second got a second
okay WR well you actually rain the
motion to start with or ought to pass
but that's
okay
yep so you speak on it yep uh so after
hearing the testimony from Captain dun
in support of the bill uh this is just a
common sense Bill to report Marine
accidents it it seems to follow much
what we do for uh automobile accidents
so I'm full support at
US representa Representative rung the
second
ditto
okay repres representative wolf you want
to speak on the bill after the vote
after the
vote well this is yeah we're going to
we're about to vote now okay all right
anybody else wish to speak on the bill
if not clerk please call the RO on a
motion of ought to pass as
amended yes on out to pass as amended
House Bill 1046 representative harb yes
representative Golds yes representative
Horgan yes clerk votes yes
representative hey yes representative
wolf yes representative McHugh yes
representative Donnelly yes yes
representative dun yes representative
Vale yes representative rung yes
representative Harvey yes representative
Simpson yes representative Baldwin yes
representative Darby yes representative
hoit yes representative L montain
yes representative Fox yes
representative Ryan yes and the chair
yes
and that is 20 to zero motion
passes motion motion having passed to
pass
it uh representative Healey you will
have
a
and gu representative bote thank you Mr
chairman um I found today's session to
be very
confusing with bills coming in that all
it takes is a copy machine malfunction
we don't have them in time I know we
can't make
rules but I'd ask as a common
courtesy let's try to get our bills out
to everybody at least two days before
you've got these bills you're sitting on
them don't wait till the last minute I'm
I'm sitting here shuffling papers and
feel like a lost fo
so as a courtesy can we and I'm not
going to make a motion or anything I'm
just asking everybody to try to get it
in at least two days
beforehand thank
you thank you
sir if they won't listen to me maybe
they'll listen to
you from my lips to God's
ears
so if you're doing a committee report
and Andy needs I mean representative
Rulo chairman Rulo um needs those
committee reports by Friday so just if
you're getting them to me get them to me
sooner thank
you thank
you there we being this uh at being in
the end of
our executive
session I well the executive session
I'll declare it closed and I will now
open the hearing
session maybe
uh open this it open the session on the
hearing
and I will
will got I'll go let people get then get
a take a minute or two
to this one which one I have a work
conflict um last
one work conflict next I want me to find
out do on Tuesday instead
or Thursday I mean I'm oh that the uh
Wetland permitting exemption to the
ER I know it's yeah I won't be able I
mean I've got a conference
Massachusetts not a vote not a vote it's
just a
work I have to go get that work session
into
the only card yeah there any other cards
on
the
okay and
you did you open it already did you open
it already no I have not opened I
haven't opened the hearing there's
another start
do do you he's leaving well I'm going to
go have to do
something is she
going it's
me been past the gavl I'm going to open
uh the hearing on HB 11 39 and the prime
sponsor representative
makoni uh thank you Mr chairman esteem
members of the committee uh nice to see
everyone in one room I walked in here
having walked out of public works with
empty chairs so apparently you were much
better drivers so uh I'm glad to see all
of you here um I um for the record my
name is Mark Maki represent the good
people of uh Carol County uh number
eight uh this summer I had the pleasure
of serving on a special commission
committee set up by the speaker uh to
identify uh hindrances to affordable
housing and what could possibly be
accomplished after a summer of looking
at rules and
regulations uh the Department of
Environmental Services uh worked hand
inand um with uh with the commission and
um we came to some ideas that we know
will have great effect going forward on
the subsurface side um septic systems is
where uh
1139 comes from um as a way of
background uh by profession I'm a I'm a
septic designer I have been for nearly
30 years um as my sons are um which I'm
proud of that also the when we are
looking at a new piece of land that it's
never been developed and a test pit is
dug to figure out where the water the
seasonal high water is in the ground uh
that's determined by permitted septic
designers and soil scientists once that
level is found then the new septic
system for the first time is built 4
feet above the bottom of it is 4 feet
above that seasonal high water I I do
have to tell you when you dig a hole in
the ground and you looking for water and
you find water that isn't necessarily
the seasonal high water there's
fluctuation in the spring in the summer
water water table goes deeper comes up
but over the course of 20 years or so a
profile is developed in the soil
coloring texture and so forth and the
skill of that Designer that soil
scientists is what determines that so if
if the water table this seasonal high
water was at grade here on the floor you
would have to build somewhere at this
height over a number of years septic
systems don't last forever and um they
used to last a lot longer in the past
but because now with the heavy
detergents medications we take um and
that sort of thing the lifespan of
septic system is much
shorter so the state has always
developed a policy that the first time
it's built here uh the second time you
evaluate the soil again but instead of
four feet it comes down to two feet
above seasonal high
water what this um what this does is in
the first place when you go to design
septic systems and you use what is
considered the standard tried and true
method in our state which is Stone
aggregate clean Stone uh three 3/4 in to
2 in as long as you're you're using that
material and you are putting 6 in of
sand under it which helps with treatment
the first design can go back at two foot
above seasonal high water as it would be
if if the system were to fail the stone
and pipe system works so well because
it's larger than the other systems that
are out there there's great voids
between the stone and the sand is is a
great agent so how does that help
housing um many of you um my age or
older know that uh as you drive around
the good land is gone you're working on
lots that are just not as s you know
acable to uh new
systems many times if you have to
develop a septic system to build a de
septic system up here for a homeowner
that involves having to add a pump into
the system a large larger septic tank
and so forth and that in turn in today's
money this wasn't the case 20 years ago
but in today's money adds thousands of
dollars into that initial
install if you're trying to develop
homes and you're trying to keep some
cost down one of one of those major
Investments is a septic system and by
permitting the septic system to be lower
in the ground and a house on a on a
traditional plane allows the sewer to
leave the house and go by gravity into
the ground into the system it it doesn't
doesn't happen every time but many times
it will so it came out of a great
recommendation out of U out of the uh
special housing committee to back this
there's a there's a great list of uh
supporters that are co-sponsors on here
and
and that is the emphasis of what we are
and it's my understanding that the
department um the department will uh
speak afterwards and uh will be in
support I'm more than happy to take
questions if I gloss over something for
you thank you representative any
questions for the
representative representative
R thank you Mr chair and thank you
represent Muki for taking my question so
if I'm to understand this so when the
initial design goes in it has to be 4
feet above the high seasonal High
Watermark correct but if that is
replaced then it only has to go be 2
feet above so this bill would just
require 2 feet at the very beginning is
that correct that is correct
representative providing you're using
stone stone and pipe or Stone Chambers
okay kind a followup Mr chair thank you
and you also mentioned something which
kind of perked my curiosity you said
that septic systems today don't last as
long because of medication and our
detergents could you explain why the um
I I'd be happy to and thank you for the
question and I'm sure the department
will have a better answer than mine um
the septic system operates uh uh
anerobic without air and with air so
when the so when it's sitting in the
tank and it's breaking down and going
through the biologic anding papers waste
and so forth it it's Anor iic there and
when you upset that chemistry how quick
things will break down inside that
concrete tank and you introduce a lot of
medications uh it it will cause the
system to stop working and die basically
in in the tank um the strong detergents
do prevent the bacterial activity to
happen in there again to break down
you're trying to break down uh nitrates
phosphates all those things before it
gets out into the field and
unfortunately um it's having a great
effect also uh Hollywood showers we have
teenagers they jump in the shower and
they generate a tremendous amount of
water that flows through the system and
it short circuits the biology and pushes
it out but but two of the major things
are medications unfortunately you can't
control that and strong
detergents
thank you any other questions for the
representative seeing none thank you for
your testimony thank you Mr
chairman next I have from the dees
Philip trobridge Mr
trobridge hello good morning uh Mr chair
and members of the committee for the
record my name is Philip tro bridge I'm
the L the manager of the land resources
program at New Hampshire Dees of which
the subsurface systems Bureau is a part
um representative makoni did a great
introduction to this bill regarding um
seasonal High the you seasonal high
water table and the reasons behind it
and the um this recommendation coming
out of the special committee for housing
uh I will not repeat that uh the
department does support this bill um we
have looked at it in terms of water
quality because obviously the question
is is there is this going to cause some
sort of problem of water quality and and
u based on our 50 years of experience
with septic systems we do not believe
that is the case we've had many cases
where systems have been put in with the
two feet of separation for a replacement
as representative mikoni mentioned and
as long as there is this six inches of
sand which is really what does the heavy
lifting of treatment for a stone and
pipe septic system uh we have found that
that is AD provides adequate treatment
for on-site
Wastewater uh we also have a lot of
experience um with other types of
systems uh there are Innovative
Technologies some of you may be familiar
with that are allowed to have reduced
separation to the groundwater and in
some cases even a smaller leech field
than a conventional system uh and again
those systems have uh proven to be
effective at treating waste uh so
looking at the the fact that we have a a
housing you know challenge in the state
uh and we wanted and there was a review
of the septic system
regulations to to see how we could
facilitate housing in a responsible way
um what the representative has put
forward we feel is effective and
responsible thank you any
questions representative rang thank you
Mr chair Mr tro thank you for taking my
question you talked about the new
technologies that require or less land
for a leech field so does the department
have rules in place to approve those
kind of systems in New Hampshire so that
you know a lot of communities that may
require a lot a minimum lot size to
handle a leech field now can maybe
adjust their zoning to accommodate the
the smaller leech Fields yes thank you
for your question um yes the department
has rules uh we we essentially approve U
certain types of Technologies with
different set backs and they have to
demonstrate performance to us to say
that they can then meet it can be as
good or better than our Stone and pipe
systems um so those that's a whole other
option that that people have and it
really depends on the lot um they tend
to be a little bit more expensive um and
uh and there's all different types so
it's and some of them require
maintenance and some of them don't so
there there's a there's additional
factors that need to be considered when
using those uh the traditional Stone and
pipe systems that we're talking about in
this bill you know are for lack of a
better word open source you know it's
not
proprietary anyone can build them um and
uh they're very tried and true
technology thank you follow just follow
one follow thank you so both both you
and uh representative makoni talked
about that one of the impetus for this
bill is housing and you know this would
help encourage more housing make it less
expensive but I was wondering what the
department thinks about when there are
housing developments or we're trying to
encourage this is to maybe step away
from septic like would septic be like
the plan a or would it be encouraged to
have a sewer system installed to service
that neighborhood or are there any type
of community community septic systems um
that you know may it it would take away
the risk of a homeowner of having a
septic system fail because all of their
septic is going to a community system is
there any movement on the department to
look at those
opportunities an excellent question um I
would say right now there are there's
move there's movement and there all of
the options that you mentioned are
allowed and discussed with any
development uh the um I think among the
development Community um water and
wastewater is starting to become a
primary question that they ask when they
talk about can we develop in this area
and there's an awareness that if you
want to do um high density housing you
really do need to be on Municipal
Services because you um you can't put 50
septic systems on a one acre lot you
know if you wanted to do a multif family
unit multif family development so and
and that's really planning that's done
at the municipal level and I know
there's been a lot of work for
municipalities to to expand their
services or understand where there's
capacity and where where there isn't uh
and to make those Investments um
Community Systems is a whole other
option and it is considered when you
have multi you know multi-unit housing
and sometimes that's the best option and
if you have a developer that is doing
one of those big developments um they're
sophisticated and they understand that
it may be better to have you know a
community system or a few community
systems rather than you know a bunch of
individual
systems representative Darby thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question um I'm so this you know this
seems like an obvious uh benefit um but
I wonder um as I this this bill amends
485 829 um and as you read through the
rest of that um that par that chapter
paragraph um there's no other sort of
explicit requirements in terms of you
know separation it it seems to be in
subsection B that it's um proposed by
the you know the department they make
the standards um and so I'm wondering
why there need to be a specific call out
here in this one case as opposed to the
department making
rules uh another excellent question um
we do have rules that have lots of other
requirements for septic systems uh
there's setbacks to surface water
uh there's setbacks to very poorly
drained soils and wetlands um setbacks
to property lines there's rules
regarding um on-site Wells it's all
kinds of things um uh I think the not
having been here when 45 was 45a was
written I suspect that at the time you
know this vertical separation to the
groundwater was seen as you know an
important setback that needed to be um
established in statute um and then would
leave it up to the department to add in
these
other um you know separation distances
through
rule oh what okay but I I didn't
understand are you saying that it the 4
feet was actually Incorporated P
previously in um 45
45a um maybe I'm not understanding so
you're saying that it was not uh I I
didn't see it I don't see any um oh
specific separation at all oh I see okay
my apologies I don't have it in front of
me so I I am uh I am am not sure the I I
believe uh the goal here is um this was
a came out of a legislative study
committee um of a a change that could be
made and I think so therefore there's a
seeking a
legislative um you know way to deal with
it as opposed to um you know I guess
seeking the rul making
change
there any other questions for the
speaker seeing none thank you for your
testimony is there anyone else here to
speak on HB
1139 I'll ask again anyone else to speak
on HB
1139 seeing none I'll close the hearing
1139 and we'll rejourn at 1 pm with HB
1140 with representative makoni again
thank
you one
o'
e
I move we
OTP
do you want to speak to your do you want
to speak to your motion yeah I just
realized I probably s just volunteered
to do the committee report
right that's why I move my
hearings no I I think uh the testimony
we heard particularly from Mr trobridge
at Dees is that uh changing this
regulation to only allow 2 feet above
the seasonal high water Mark has shown
to be sufficient on replacement so it it
makes sense that it should be sufficient
for new development as well thank you do
you wish to speak to your second
representative ghoul
no any further discussion on the motion
ought to
pass seeing i' ask the clerk to call the
rle and maybe you could give me
their my Green Sheet back oh the green
sheet
yeah thank you okay thank you very much
acting chair um am I going to call you
first representative harb
yes representative GS yes representative
forgan yes clerk votes yes
representative Healey yes representative
wolf yes representative MCU
not here representative Donnelly yes
representative Dunn
yes representative Vale
yes representative rung
yes um no I call didn't I call you
represent
wolf okay
sorry it's me it's me it's my age do I
get two votes If I
Stay
thank you for checking though that's
it's good to have a spot check uh we do
have some members missing representative
Harvey not here uh representative
Simpson yes representative
Baldwin not here not here and
representative Derby is here
yes and represent ho is not here
representative ho not here uh
representative L
montain here representative Fox not here
representative Ryan
not here and the chair yes so that is 13
y zero days motion passes Mr
CH yes representative
v um just to mention that the three
three people have left um because
they're of the weather and they need to
get
home thank you can we put this on
consent yes yes consent
okay thank you moved out of out of
executive session we'll move out and go
to the regular hearing scheduled for
1:00 and I'll turn it over to the
chair House Bill 1140 relative to to
requirements for Homeowner installation
of septic systems CH
recognizes the
sponsor Mr MC representative MCC
chairman
M thank
you thank you Mr chairman steam members
once again uh I do have to make comment
Public Works was slow getting in today
but all of our members are still sitting
there we're not worried about snow going
on
so the um there is a um so I'm here to
introduce um uh House Bill 1140 Bill
enables homeown to install replacement
of Waste Disposal Systems and their own
domicile their house without a permit
there is an amendment um that I'm
wondering uh which is what the
department is going to testify to uh I
don't know that I'm able to offer the
amendment we passed it out as you had
suggested Mr chairman or can I offer the
amendment I I would uh well you can
offer the amendment okay thank Mr
chairman I would like I would like to
offer Amendment uh
9h which is an amendment to house Bill
1140 should be a copy on everyone's desk
and I had given the chairman u a copy
also and my comments will will uh come
back to address that
Amendment so presently in the
regulations in the rules um department
environmental services
subsurface um
homeowners uh have the ability to
install their own septic
system providing they meet all of the
requirements that are in the rules um
scarify the surface make sure that it's
clean all the materials are the same
standard uh they have to follow the
blueprint that's provided the approved
septic design to the
T um and that that has been in statute
for as long as as I've been out 30 30
plus years but there's there's been an
issue with the process as it is right
now uh there have been some
abuses um one of which uh now that land
and homes and everything are at Peak uh
pricing um you were always it was always
intended that you were the owner of the
home I bought a piece of land I'm the
owner of the home I'm I'm a crafty
person man or woman I can you know build
a building I can do my own Plumbing I
can do my electric I sure as heck can do
a septic
system um but what ended up happening is
it happened in my area I'm I'm in the uh
Carol County is um some people started
saying I'm here's what I'm going to do
I'm going to buy a piece of land I'm
going to build a house I'm going to tell
the building inspector I'm going to tell
the state that I'm doing all the work
myself and that it's going to be the
home that I'm going to move into and I'm
going to live in and that's why I should
be able to do it but what they're doing
is they're skirting the system they'll
they'll build the house they'll build
their septic system and they'll offer
the home for sale immediately and move
on to the next the next system so they
they might be they might be handy at at
framing um and I'd like to say that it's
rocket science me myself my family are
septic installers I'd like to say it's
science but it's not but it it it does
involve a high degree of following
elevations and slopes and everything
else and the department was running this
was brought in by the department the
department was running into problems
that when they send their Regional
inspectors out uh one issue is they have
no idea how it was supposed to be built
uh they don't know how far a baffle
should extend in they've using the wrong
pipe they're sloped incorrectly and it's
causing the Department to go back three
and four times in some cases five times
uh to oversee this and in my area we've
had the abuse of developers and I guess
my and and I've also developed property
so believe me I'm not putting a blanket
over developers but uh there are some
individuals that would would buy a
subdivision and build each house sell
that house move to the next one and they
were doing this continuously and the
department was was knowing that and
seeing problems so the reason um that's
the emphasis and I will let the
department uh speak to to that but in a
sense it it's permitting a home owner
and they're going to have to sign an
affidavit as I understand it that
they're going to remain in the home for
two years um that they themselves are
going to be the
person um that is going to make do the
install they're not going to hire
subcontractors and I believe that uh
most
importantly uh in item three the
property owner will hire permitted
septic system designer or permitted
installer to certify that the system is
built the way it was intended to be so
it will it'll be an education for them
and then the construction will be
overseen uh to make sure that it was
built correctly because is when the when
the state comes to the
inspection they're seeing the top of the
field and how does the top of the field
and they and they'll see some piping and
it's in going in these directions but
they don't see what's between the top of
the system and down to grade and by
allowing some oversight and that's very
important if Dirk gets run into the
stone or other things it'll shortcircuit
the life of the system so uh the
department had asked me to bring this
forward and I'm happy to answer
questions and I know Mr throwbridge is
here to explain it in much better
detail just a just a question uh on
procedure uh you're you're uh you wish
to speak to the amendment also or just
to the bill itself I apologize Mr
chairman I was speaking to the amendment
the am okay that's fine that's fine I
just the amendment replaces the uh LSR M
all right any questions uh by members of
the
committee represent representative Bron
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question so
if I'm not to understand this right I'll
use my own example so let's say my
septic system fails and I'm going
decideed I'm I need to save some money I
want to have it done quickly I'm going
to do it myself so if I use the same
design of the original septic system I
can go and have that work done I just
it's just if I have a new design I have
to have a uh a certified designer do
that so they there're
and so that you have you have two
methods that you're your use if you are
uh as a with a new septic system you as
a homeowner under conditions can build
can build that septic system with a
state approved design or you would would
hire a permitted installer to do that
your I think your questions further on
is that I have a home the septics failed
I have a previously approved septic
system can I just go ahead and rebuild
that and I think that there are
conditions on the age and so forth that
would permit that but I think that would
be better answered by the department
okay thank you and then one followup Mr
and then so this affidavit um that the
they'll live in the domicile for at
least two years I don't really
understand the relevance of that because
we have people that know they have a
septic system in failure and they still
live in the house so um you know we know
just from the some of the testimony
we've had around septic systems in the
Shoreland area that you know some people
do but it doesn't behold someone to have
to live in that house I mean I'm Wonder
wondering people who maybe have a
transfer a work transfer or something
and they may have signed this domicile
but they I mean this affidavit but then
they realize oh my gosh I'm being
transferred next you know within that
two
years I'm just wondering what what's the
purpose of having that
affidavit the
it's how much how much teeth is in item
number four I can't tell you it's meant
to be a deterrent to stop that developer
from buying one home building it and
moving over to the next one so at least
there's a paper trail that the
department if they find that this person
is is there will always be latitude for
exactly what you're saying your work
takes you away and you have to sell the
home there there's no penalty attached
to this my understanding and and um Mr
to bridge will address it further it's
it's to put that person that flips homes
um aware of the fact that they're not to
be doing
that question representative
representative wolf then representative
Don thank you Mr chairman um thank you
for taking my
questions um so somebody can come in and
put in a new
system and tell you that they' complied
with all the rules and regulations is
there anybody do they have to have an
inspection before they cover it
over yes representative they do so it's
a two-part process um so you the
designer comes in or the soil scientist
or the engineer comes in and says this
is this is what you're going to build
and it's state approved and it's been
reviewed step number one by the state
step number two is that who someone
that's permitted to build that or a
homeowner that's following the same
regulations then goes out and constructs
that system after they've constructed
that system before they can get an
operational approval which is what the
state says in the town I believe before
they will grant an OP a um certificate
of occupancy the state comes out and
inspects the septic system it's a
two-part system did that answer your
question okay so they they can't
go forward without the state inspection
correct once it's been built once it's
been
built okay I and again as representative
run said I don't know why the two-year
thing is in there I'd like to see some
sort of
monetary uh penalty because somebody's
going to file an affidavit okay and they
don't do anything they they sell it
they're long gone they've sold that
house they're onward to the next seven
houses they build
them
that's I understand the point be the
prerogative of the
committee representative ding question
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question um I in here it says a
permitted septic system installed uh can
you tell me how someone gets a to become
a certified septic system installer what
is the what is the organization that
actually certifies you as a septic
system installer and uh what's that
process okay so in in our state um the
Department of Environmental Services
subsurface overseas permitting of
persons with qualifications to be
designers or installers or
both the state also has a license
procedure not to muddle it so people
that inspect septic systems that's a
license but the permitting for designers
and installers is done by the department
um the requirement it's going to be
discussed later in another hearing here
is that they are to take a test a
written test that's offered I believe
once or twice a year um and have to have
some
um uh credentials as having been in the
business and passed the test and they
they are given a
permit sentive harp for a question thank
you represent thank you representative
for taking my
question um it looks like in number
three you're
really suggesting that I get an ASB
built plan even though you say a letter
wouldn't that be similar to a as built
plan because you have the septic
approved plan but then when you're
normally done would you not get an as
built plan this just says you're going
to get a letter or certification but
wouldn't you be just
like the dees I'm doing my work I finish
it if I don't have you overseeing every
letter you don't know how much sand I
have you don't know where I put the
pipes so I'm not against the idea
somebody should look at it but it's
almost as if how you going to really do
that and is it going to lead to an as
built plan
situation the presently in regulations
when you're doing an install if
everything everything on a house site
can move a house can move the septic
tank can move the piping can move the
only thing that has to stay in that
place is the septic field itself it has
to remain there
the word as built typically comes in uh
when the septic tank got moved the house
got moved or piping got moved and the
installer Andor homeowner in limited
instances where homeowner can do that is
obligated by the department to have that
amended plan available so all those
changes so when the inspector comes he
sees or she sees what is there what
happened years ago the Department wasn't
requiring it today it's an assurance to
you as the new homeowner that that's
where things are but if nothing changed
and everything stayed where it was you
wouldn't necessarily need that amended
plan I don't know if that helps you sir
or want to rephrase
it might I or a
followup I'll try to rephrase it how are
you going to be able to certify as the
installer that it was done properly if
you weren't like a clerk of the works
watching them do
it
okay the depart the department has been
wrestling with this issue for a long
time with the homeowner install and it's
been interpreted differently by the
department on what they can do and can't
do and the current
interpretation um
a homeowner a homeowner presently can't
so a homeowner's built their septic
system and they're ready for they're
ready for it to be inspected there's not
a mechanism out there right now for the
home owner to enter the system digitally
and say it's time for inspection so the
homeowners had to be going through an
installer to get that
done and if this has happened in my
area and it has
then as we get involved as the installer
I won't certify I won't call in that
plan unless I've seen four or five steps
happen because I don't want my name
associated with it I I think they're
trying they're trying to work out this
issue but um if in the future if this
were to pass I can assure you if someone
came to our company our family business
to do this we are going to want to see
the soil before it was you know that it
was cleared materials were correct and
everything
else so you would look at it can I have
one
followup I I'm represent Builders but I
don't do septic systems so I I'm sort of
trying to follow the idea and it was
mentioned that the homeowner can have
the system done unless he Subs it out to
somebody but I'm a homeowner I'm going
to sub out the guy that's going to bring
the sand I'm going to sub out the guy
that's going to bring the pipes I'm I'm
not bringing all that somebody's going
to install the sand they're going to
excavate they're going to so I'm the GC
the general
contractor but I'm not doing the work
I'm just the GC so I don't know how this
fits into the homeowner does it okay so
thank you for the question and you bring
up several GR points and if you took the
little interpretation it would say that
I had to go get the pipe and I had do
everything else um and for a septic
installer doing this work himself he
does exactly what you just mentioned we
call have tanks delivered and all that
sort of thing what they're trying what
the the intent is when it comes time to
put that pipe in the ground in the stone
or plastic tubes or whatever it is
they're using the intent is that the
homeowner is actually doing that work oh
okay thank because otherwise you need to
have a permitted installer to do it and
that's what these developers are doing
they're not they're not you know go
ahead Jim you know take your backo over
there and go to
work okay thank you very much
sure any other questions by members of
the
committee oh actually do you have a
question no okay because representative
wolf
thank you U Mr chairman and thank you
for taking the question has this bill
been brought forth
by the U contractors Association or
Dees and so what is Dees hoping to get
out of this bill they'll they'll be
testifying right after okay thank you
representative wolf it was brought
through me uh from the Department
okay thank you I'm just not sure that
we're going to get the protection that
we have now Dees does a wonderful
job inspecting systems along the process
certainly and I think that was maybe
looking at more problems than solving
thank
you anyone else
representative we septic system that
includes piping from the house to the
tank
problem
system thank thank you for the question
so when we speak of a septic system most
most of the regulation is about the
leech field itself in the tank that it's
connected to um the plan says how those
things are going there how the tanks
constructed in the piping you are not
permitted to make a repair to a septic
field without a plan in hand uh there
are some instances is a homeowner if you
have a pipe that's broken from the house
to the to the tank you can do that if
you have my understanding is a septic
tank um that is there's there's baffles
in there the baffles are uh waste comes
into the tank and it drops it down into
the uh the tank as opposed to letting it
float and the same thing when it goes
out there's a baffle so you're drawing
from what they call called the clear
Zone if those baffles were to break or
to fail you could do that work and not
need a permit to do that but they when
the state comes to to inspect the final
product they look at the septic field
the septic tank and all the
piping within four feet of the building
they they can't go into the building and
an installer cannot make Plumbing
changes inside a building I don't know
if that helps you
representative Harvey bu thank you very
much real quick question um thank you
for that uh clarification now yes uh
homeowner can't replace the septic field
can they replace just the sand or can
they add sand no no okay that also
requires a designer installer okay thank
you oops sentive from thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question so the
um powers that we're giving the
homeowners to do this work that's under
this
amendment just in your professional
opinion um representative makoni how
many of them do you think would could do
an adequate job with just the average
homeowner because it seems I'm I'm just
getting the sense that for a homeowner
to be able to take advantage of this
they would have to have a lot of
specialized skills
that we now put on to septic system
installers how many people could
actually do that work themselves okay as
I mentioned I'm I'm a family business I
my sons are all designers and myself and
and we will
process out of out of let's say the last
100 septic designs we've we've submitted
I have probably had eight people that
were trades people that could very
easily do it themselves
it's not a it's not a really large
percentage but they sit there scratching
their head that I've moved made a
conscious move to come to New Hampshire
the live fre or die State and you're
telling me I can't build a septic system
and you know I own trucks and I know how
to use a laser level and so forth It's
not a huge percentage but it's um it's
warranted they've always had the ability
I I believe it's just tightening up the
rains a
little
right anyone
else seeing no one thank you very much
thank you Philip throwbridge
good morning good afternoon Mr chairman
and members of the committee um for the
record my my name is Philip Trowbridge
I'm the manager of the land resources
management program at New Hampshire
Dees um so uh representative Muni has
done an excellent job of I think
describing a lot of the background
associated with this bill so I'm um not
going to cover that material um what I
want to say clearly is that the
department supports this
bill um and that we feel that this is an
improvement over the current
situation uh the current statute allows
for these homeowner
installations um without any of the
safeguards that we'd be adding through
this amendment the uh the oversight by a
permanent installer the certification by
through an affidavit that this house is
not going to be flipped um for
development um and that those are the
things that we've had the biggest
challenge with over
time um representative harb you asked
about you know as builts and how this is
different
uh one of the things I wanted to point
out is that um the area below the septic
system the base the base of it below the
Lee field uh needs to be what's called
scarified so they'll excavate down to
where the base of the leech field should
be but then there also should use
equipment to to loosen up the
soil uh and to prepare that bed bottom
for the leech field it's something that
we cannot observe as the state when we
come in later and and we're just um
looking at really the top of the system
and that's if you notice in the
amendment on
line um
15 we called out specifically um the
including but not limited to the base of
the affluent disposal area as one of the
things that we feel very strongly that
the you know this installer who was
overse seeeing the project would would
look at because that's really kind of
where a lot of these systems succeed or
fail and and so it's a little you know
the the as built might look the same as
you know the leechfield is at this
elevation it's in this area but that
preparation of the basil area um is
something that have to be observed at
that time and representative Maki
alluded to that of saying there's a few
things that he'd want to be seeing uh to
certify to make that
certification um we also added a
safeguard to say that the property owner
or a permited septic system installer
perform all the work to construct with
the Waste Disposal system that's at line
12 um this is getting to the point of
the intent here is that we're not hiring
subcontractors we're not hiring the uh
landscapers to do the work and so it's
it's kind of it's saying there are those
people who have these skills they have
the equipment and um you know the
legislature had established this you
know Authority for them to do this for
their own domicile uh but we're trying
to distinguish the people who really can
do that for their own domile from people
who are just uh trying to do uh trying
to avoid the cost of hiring a permanent
installer uh so I I think you know some
of the conversation here today has been
about you know we're adding uh or
granting authorities um to to homeowners
that they didn't have and um yeah we're
actually constraining those authorities
um and uh we recognize uh and the reason
why there there's an amendment here
today is um you know there was we
received some comment of people saying
there are legitimate cases where someone
want you know he's building the house
from the floor up they're pouring the
foundation they're doing the plumbing
they're doing the electrical work
and why can't they do the sepic system
too and so we wanted to add that with
these safeguards so that you know that
you know that right is um you know is
available to the the people where it's
appropriate
um so uh I think I was
um representative wolf you asked
represent wolf is not here sorry
representative wolf asked asked about
monetary penalties and if there you know
the section of the RSA that we refer to
um for penalties 45 a43 which is
on line 21 that's the section of RSA
that deals with fines and other
penalties so you know what we would
Envision is you know if there was an
egregious violation uh that we could
find an
individual uh for um violating this
portion of the
statute
um I believe those were most of the the
questions that were asked and I'd be
happy to take any further questions
representative Donley for
question thank you thank you Mr chair um
how many permitted installers does New
Hampshire have across the state um thank
you for the question we have rough a
little less than
2,000 any other questions members of the
the commit
representative run for a question thank
you Mr chair and thank you Mr trobridge
for taking my question when a setic
system is replaced or a new septic
system installed is it only Dees that
inspects that is there a requirement by
local town code officer to do an
inspection excellent question uh it
depends on the town some if a town has a
local ordinance that requires a town
inspection then yes and that is all done
before the state process um you know
before the state inspection U but if um
that all depends on the town and if they
have that local
ordinance so hypothetical let's say if a
town all towns have an ordinance that a
septic system either a new a replacement
has to be inspected by the the town code
officer would that alleviate a lot of
some issues that may be presented with
this bill so if you have an owner doing
their own work you know the the town
could be enabled to adopt these
ordinances that would provide that
ongoing inspection and I mentioned this
I've had two septic systems replaced
over 40 years different properties but
um there was somebody from the town that
came out and looked a few times they
they came out to confirm the seasonal
high water mark they came to look at
everything before it was closed up so so
I I guess I just assume that was going
on if throughout the
state very good question um the there
are relatively few towns that have these
ordinances um I I'm going I don't know
the exact number but it's say it's
between 30 and
50 um and so it is the minority of the
towns that have ordinances and code
enforcement officers who are able to do
those inspections and then of course it
depends what the ordinance says and if
the ordinance is about um set you know
there's something they're primarily
looking at setbacks or they're P only
going to visit the site you know when
it's ready to be backfilled like right
before the state um versus in this case
where we want to call out that someone
should look at
it um you know after the initial
excavation to see if the basil area has
been properly prepared um so I we think
that this is setting the kind of the the
minimum standard that that should be
established should be held throughout
the state and obviously towns are have
the right to provide or to create more
strict
ordinance representative G and
representative D does this does these
inspections hold up people getting
things
done um excellent question um I'd say
from our state inspections uh I'm very
proud of our team we do our inspections
within one to two days which is really
pretty remarkable
uh we have a great team that covers the
whole state so we are are not holding
things up um and I'd say in the instance
here where you'd be working with an
installer um you know I I would you
would have a that would be under
contract between the the owner and the
installer for the work and it's for
compensation so I would expect the you
know the um the oversight to be done in
a timely
way okay representative Donnelly then
representative hary thank you Mr chair
thank you um what's the additional cost
on average for having a an installer
versus saying someone who does it
themselves excellent question we we've
been kind of trying to Ballpark that and
um our estimate on this is is if someone
were really doing this entirely
themselves they have their own equipment
they're going to have to hire an
installer to provide oversight they're
going to have to buy a you know
materials um we think it probably cuts
the cost of a septic system in
half um you know and right now just for
reference you know septic systems cost
are costing between you know 25 and
$35,000 thank you is great uh testimony
and about how many um representative
makoni was talking about the house the
individual say uh developer or whatnot
is doing the house flipping and then
moving on and you're discovering these
bad systems say how often did that
happen last year in and years prior if
you have that number thank
you yeah you guys are asking all the
hard questions
sorry we've been trying to tease that
out and we have we do keep records of of
this and there's an we try and separate
things that are like new construction
versus like a repair
um sometimes the you know our our our
database does not distinguish like
replacement from new construction so we
haven't been able to tease it all out um
I'd say in the not in the last year but
in you know several years ago when this
was really um a more active thing we
were getting on the order of let's just
say we were getting like about 150
homeowner
installations each year that we were
dealing with we subsequently had a legal
interpretation of domicile which said
domicile has to be a place where you're
actively living so how can it be new
construction and so we were um you
know uh getting the word out that that's
not how this should be used and the
numbers did come down but there were
still a whole number that came in
because people would you know go ahead
with their work and then call to us and
say I've already put it all in you know
I'm you know I've invested $20,000 you
know you need
to you know how can I handle this and
this is where they would call an
installer to come and you know take over
responsibility for the system you know
so uh we went you know it was a pretty
significant
number uh in the years past it's fewer
now uh but what I feel like is good
about this legislation is it it really
takes the ambiguity out of when this is
allowable and when it isn't and the
process someone needs to follow if they
want to do this homeowner installation I
expect it won't be large numbers that
can meet these um can meet these
requirements but I think for those that
it can it's the the right thing to
do anyone else for for a
question seeing none thank you very much
thank you very
much having no more F
cards I'll bring the uh
hearing to a
close on House Bill
we I don't know you think we should go
on head on this one or not prob probably
probably wait
you want to reject this one or not or we
have no okay I see people I see some
questions
um look of angst on some people's face
so we won't we not go we will not
exercise
the we'll proceed with
caution well I
just we're about to L theum I think
we got to decide now yeah speak now
forever hold your
peace
y
nice
Sha
I'm there's nobody here now so thank you
sir all
right open the hearing on House Bill 141
relative to requirements for approval to
increase load on a sewage Disposal
system representative representative
makoni the floor is yours thank you Mr
chairman um
members um I'm here for the introduction
House Bill uh 1141 disposal relative
requirements for approval to increase
load on a sewage Disposal system I was
asked by the department to bring forth
uh several new uh changes and this is
one of them and without having to listen
to me once again I would defer to the
department Mr rbridge to explain the
necessity of this
legislation
okay once
[Laughter]
Burns Bitten Twice
Shy all right after M Mr chairman
members of the committee for the record
my name is Philip trobridge manager of
the land resources program at New
Hampshire Dees representative makoni has
done such an excellent job of
introducing all the other
bills now I have to uh do this one uh so
I'll give the background on this bill um
there's a section of the statute uh 45a
38 you know regarding you know what what
we do when someone there's an existing
structure and there's going to be an
increase uh some sort of change to that
structure either it changed to the size
of it or changed to the occupancy or
something that's going to affect the
septic
system um and we found that there's
there's a couple of things that need to
be fixed um the the way the statues
written now it it it really talks about
um you know expanding a structure or
occupying um the structure at you know
more than uh part you know going from
part-time to full-time occupancy as you
know ways to increase the load but we've
learned in um recent years is that
there's a lot of other ways you can
increase the load on a septic system uh
most notably uh bringing in um a a
commercial kitchen kitchen operation um
a lot of home businesses sprang up
during the pandemic where people are
making uh you know going from you know
just doing their normal cooking to
making things for products for sale and
and there there's a lot of food waste
that goes down the drain in that case
there's also a lot of fat oils and
grease that go down the drain so that
that chemical load is also an increased
load um and we we found ourselves in
debate with some applicants in the past
because they're saying well I mean I'm
not expanding the structure I'm not
changing the occupancy but you know
we're trying to tell you that your
system is going to go into failure if
you don't you know increase the capacity
of it so what the one of the first
changes that we have in the bill um on
uh lines three and four is just
basically saying any change in use um
you know to it's kind of Encompass all
the situations where you could have a
change in use that would require um some
sort of Permitting and I should be clear
what happens when when someone has a
change in use is they either have to
demonstrate to us that their system has
the capacity for the new use which is
which can happen people can have
oversized
systems uh and you know they're adding a
bedroom but they had built a set larger
septic system originally and so the
everything works out um or they have to
have a design for a system that can
handle their use and the design
basically says you have the space and
you can meet the lot loading um for that
system um and so then you know that that
allows us to proceed with
approvals uh the statute is one of the
harder statutes to follow um for
as you get further down uh Roman uh 2- a
talks about cases where you're doing
some change of use but you're not
increasing the
load and it's exempting that from
permitting it's not in the bill or I
guess it is part of it's in the bill but
if you're looking at the actual statute
and and what that is is saying is that
if you're you know you're not changing
the use or not changing the load um uh
and you have a state approved system you
know you don't need to come in for
permitting there was also an exemption
of if if you were on a lot that was more
than five
acres and uh when that was put in the
statute originally it was a way to make
things a little bit easier for
manufactured housing Parks because uh
there would be uh units that were sort
of coming on the site and going off the
site and um there might be some small
changes to the structure but you know we
wanted to facilitate permitting for that
um the problem has been is it what we're
seeking to add now is to say if the lot
is more than five acres in size and is
served by an approved septic system
would would have this
exemption um because it's been 50 years
plus since the
subsurface uh jurisdiction
began uh and it it doesn't make a lot of
sense to to allow you know a 60-year-old
system that was substandard to continue
to be used um if there's going to be you
know a new building brought
in um so I think when the the 5 acre um
exemption was put in you know people
there were there is it was to facilitate
this work on mobile home parks but it
was also someone thought well if you got
five acres you know you're unlikely to
be impacting your neighbors you know
there's a lot of flexibility here uh but
when you have a kind of a d densely
packed uh manufactured housing Park and
a number of systems that are very old
and not state approved um I think for
water quality protections uh it's
prudent to require that those come up to
current
code uh so the the department supports
this bill um we think it will clarify
for applicants when they need to come in
for permitting and it also um you know
removes that loophole of the acre
Parcels uh that is has the potential to
affect water
quality thank you and I'm happy to take
your
questions representative harb and
representative Horan thank you for
taking my
question um my question is on the
amendment B and C I'm just wondering why
don't you have a number of years from
approval of construction because and a
allot the other bills sometimes stimes
they say if it's more than 20 years you
still need to come back there's no year
here and you just mentioned you've been
in business 50 years so I could have a
50y old approved system yeah excellent
point um if you if you look at the full
statute there there's an a above that
that um is you know the lot is served by
a system that's with it was approved
within 20 years so we already do have
that 20year cut off it would be
I
think uh fine to add the 20-year cut
offs to B and C I think we were just
trying to be as um as light a touch as
we
could and and so it's at the pleasure of
the committee if you'd like to amend
that follow for a followup just would
like it to be consistent because if I
file on to be with a 50y old system I'd
still be okay but if you really want 20
on a I just thought why don't we have 20
on B and C sure
okay my position but thank you for your
comment thanks sen
Morgan thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question uh when we talk
about expansion of the system or loading
increasing the loading this could
literally mean replacing the tank and
the size of the Le field
correct um essentially a new system yeah
yeah normally it involves both um there
there can be cases where someone has
used an oversized tank you know and then
does not need to change the tank but
normally if their system the system is
sized for a certain flow both the tank
and a leech field and if they need to
increase that flow they'd have to change
both thank
you thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
trob for taking my question um the the
addition of the language any change in
use is that going to be defined
anywhere um because there may be a
homeowner that let's say they are having
a home business and they figured I'm
just making stuff in my home they may
not regard that as a change in use is it
going to be like how would people know
that they would have to notify their
apartment if they are starting like a
home food
business that's a very good question um
I I think the where I would start with
the answer is um you know the full text
would read any change in use which would
increase the load on the sewage Disposal
system um and so I think that that
already constrains it so if you're
starting a you know a knitting business
or something you know obviously that's
not going to uh change the the increase
the load on the sewage um uh Disposal
system um and uh so so we're already
kind of constraining it that way way the
question is you know if I'm you know
just uh you know
I've well let me break it down into some
categories no we uh permit residences
based on the number of bedrooms for
example and there the assumption is that
you know there's all the bedrooms are
used and there you know there's so many
people per bedroom so much flow per
bedroom you can have cases where the
kids go gone off to college and you know
there's you still have a three-bedroom
house but there's only two people living
there um the we wouldn't consider that a
change of use or a change of use if the
kids come back you know like the the
structure is still the same the number
of bedrooms is the same so it's only if
someone were to say I'm going to add a
fourth bedroom or I'm going to add an
Adu that we would say that that's a
change in
use um and then in terms of these home
businesses um there's food licensing
requirements that happen uh so when
someone is um you know in some cases
they need to get food licensing and they
have to then check the health department
DHHS uh needs something from us to
verify that they have an approved septic
system so that would be a time for us to
be saying uh yeah we didn't uh they're
not approved to have you know the ice
cream stand or something like that um I
know there's a number of bills in the
house
um this session regarding artisanal
foods and I think you know recognizing
that there's some you know very small
scale operations and that they you know
the permitting on those is going to be
done handled in a certain way but when
it reaches the threshold that it needs a
you know a food license from DHHS then
we would be
notified any other questions
representative Donald thank
you it says a sewage disposal system
does this mainly pertain to septic
systems versus sore systems uh thank you
for the question it's an excellent point
yes and whenever possible we try and
change it to septic system this was the
older language that's been in 45a for
forever um but yes sewage Disposal
system you know on anything this is this
is relating to septic Syms and not
Municipal sewer Municipal sewer loads
are handled through the you know sewer
use ordinances things like
that just thank
you representative
harb thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking this question I'm following
on your idea of the change of use with
the Adu if I had a three-bedroom place
and then I put on a one-bedroom Adu but
do we have a provision in our
regulations that I could put a and a
restriction on my property that says I'm
only going to have so many bedrooms and
I decommission one of the bedrooms in my
house to allow the
Adu um that's a very good question I uh
do not believe there is a way that we
could could say uh I have a
three-bedroom house but I'm you know
we're only going to use two of it and
there you know the the flow for the Adu
is going to be you know the extra flow
for the Adu is compensated by this
reduced use of the bedroom uh no I don't
think we can do that okay thank you
anyone else for a
question may maybe you sced of going I
have I have a question going back to
this change of use and taking and what
uh representative harb puts speaks of
bedrooms uh is can you can you make a
bedroom can you make a bedroom a den
when you make a bedroom a storage
closet
uh it yes any room can be converted to a
bedroom but if you it depends what you
want to call it at the time or is what
you or is there you can do you have a a
form that you can say I want to change
this now from a bedroom to a den or a a
place a kennel for my dog
yeah very interesting scenario I I I
believe a lot of this is handled at the
local taxation level um in the
assessments for the property um because
you know that's normally what is the
governing dis you know um description of
the property is the number of bedrooms
the number of
bathrooms um you know over overall
square footage um so it's not that that
you the department is you can rece can
make those decisions can say okay we
received a petition now this is we've
removed the closet it's no longer a
bedroom it's a Den now my house is a
two-bedroom I don't think anything we
say would hold any sway over the town
assessor who's going to say no that's
still a three-bedroom house um and so
that that really isn't our purview uh to
make that decision just but
the uh your but it maybe a three-bedroom
house but if I if I'm calling it
a so you are going by the decision of
the Town assessor and not by the what
what the uh you what the what the person
say yes from an official record we are
um when someone comes to us for approval
they're coming to say this is a
three-bedroom house or so this is a
four-bedroom house that's what the
design is based on that's what the flows
are based on and that and that you know
that's mostly what we're looking at is
what the application tells us um and I
think what you're talking about is you
somewhere down the line someone's been
approved as a four-bedroom house they
want to say no it's not four bedrooms
it's you know three bedrooms and a
um and a large Den um I you know we have
not been involved in those decisions
because we
we would go off of what the tax card
shows us okay but let's say they were to
say I want to be you know for I'm
approved for four
bedrooms and I'm what I'm converting it
to is you know two bedrooms and an
Adu you know the which is an Adu is
Believe It or Not considered one and a
half bed bedrooms just for flow uh uh
you know that would be within the
capacity of their septic system and it
for us that would not be a change AB use
okay that would increase the flow on the
septic
system anyone
else seeing no one else thank you very
much all right thank you very much I
have no other
cards and unfortunately we cannot hurry
up we have to wait around so the
uh
because it's already been
published
JNS
huh
okay uh well we can always you can
always do
that what we may want to think about
doing then is in the evening I have a
several bills we just go 10 o'clock go
from one o'clock on and change the thing
yeah that's the way this it's like the
way
this
e
thank you Mr chair for the record my
name is representative Rosemary rung I
represent Hillsboro 12 which is the town
of
marac um on behalf of Representative
makoni I am introducing HB 1142 and will
defer any questions to um Mr trobridge
from New Hampshire
Dees is
he
huh
okay throwbridge with the cony me
normally it
was him first but he's not here so you
mind uh I taking you out of
order Philip throwbridge from New
Hampshire
de Floor is yours thank you Mr chair
members of the committee for the record
my name is Philip trobridge I'm the
manager of the land resources program at
New Hampshire Dees
um for a bill that we heard earlier
today uh HB 1140 we already discussed
some of the reasons you know uh for
having the requirements to be licensed
to or to be permitted to install a
septic system um just I think to
underscore the importance of it um when
someone the types of skills that we're
looking for when someone is getting the
permit from us is uh they must pass an
exam uh on the topics such as septic
system design and installation
procedures drafting plans to scale
regulations regarding sewage loading and
setbacks and acceptable field
adjustments from approved plans um this
is uh this permitting is necessary for
protecting Public Health in the
environment uh because if the system is
not designed and and installed properly
it will fail prematurely resulting in an
immediate public health hazard
so this bill
hb142 pertains to the requirements to
obtain such a
license um DS runs the permitting
program to to uh to issue the installer
and designer
permits we hold exams for these uh both
of these permits twice per year and last
year we had over 200 candidates uh
combined for installers and designers
who took the
exam however I I regret to say that over
80% of those taking the exams did not
pass um many of these people then retake
the exam um which drives up the number
of people in the exams uh and it also
increases the state resources to
administer this exam to large numbers of
people uh the root of the problem from
our perspective is that uh people think
they can pass the exam by just reading
the de
uh subsurface system rules and that's
part of it some of those things we need
to know um but they also need this a
foundation in preparing and reading
plans and construction techniques um
these there's not a lot of opportunities
for um classes in which to learn that
there were more opportunities in the
past um and what we found is the most
effective way to obtain these skills is
through OB on the job training working
under someone who's already permitted to
be a licensed a permitted installer or
designer uh and so taking a cue from
some of the other uh uh certification
boards associated with
Dees um we looked at their regulations
and and we saw that some of those
require um a few years of experience in
the trade before you can sit for the
exam and uh so we thought that that
would be the you know appropriate way to
add to the requirements for the exam is
to require this training in the field of
septic system installation and design uh
two years for the case of a designer and
one year in the case of an
installer um and you know allow them to
sit for the that that they need to
demonstrate to us before they could uh
register for the
exam uh so you know this is a uh you
know the department brought this
language to representative mccon
um at this point in our our letters
we're we're not taking a position and
I'll explain why um it's we we we've
received some questions since we brought
it up about how this bill relates to
some of the bills that were in the in
the past session um hb2 regarding um
licensing certifications for a number of
professionals um and that sought to
reduce licensing requirements so we
thought our approach should be just to
provide the technical information about
this issue
to the committee and leave the the
decision to the
legislature uh should this committee
decide to move forward with the bill we
do recommend an amendment uh which is uh
listed on page two of the letter um and
it's it's um just the addition of few
sentences to give us rul making
Authority related to these exams uh and
that would be necessary so that we can U
specify the types of uh
on the job training that would be
acceptable for the one to two years um
and that's the way some of the other
certification programs do this they they
have a broad requirement in statute and
then have rules that say you know these
are if you do these things um this
counts as you're on the job
training so thank you for the
opportunity to testify and I'm happy to
take your
questions
representative I okay
yeah
okay earlier we said uh you we had said
that this wasn't rocket science um I
just want to know how you came up with
the two
years thank you for your question um we
we looked at the other programs and some
of them um required three years some of
them required um less and I think we we
made a judgment call as to you know that
this would you know no how many years um
would seem appropriate for the level of
responsibility and so we thought there
should be a higher number of years for
the designers because it's a more
complicated
task uh and then less so for the
installers and so you know it's it uh
that's where we came up with the two
years for designers and one year for
installers thank you Mr chair thank you
Mr troid for taking my question um so
just looking at the situation with
people trying to get contractors in the
state would this slow things down um for
getting somebody um licensed or would it
speed things up an excellent question um
it is our sincere hope that this speeds
things up um the the pass rate on this
exam is a very frustrating to me um we
are spend a lot of time preparing the
exam and admiss ing the exam and doing
Outreach about the exam and uh and yet
our pass rate is not you know improved
in the last few years since I've been in
charge of the
program uh and so we did some hard
thinking about what we could do to try
and change that course to change that
trajectory because we have you know a
certain number of people who are
retiring from the trade each year as
designers and installers and we need to
replace those people uh so I think this
will will um will help because people
will have the foundation that they need
and as we look at the new exam or at the
exam sorry not as we're looking newly at
the exam we've been trying to pinpoint
where people are getting it wrong and
we've been finding it's these
foundational things of how to read a
plan uh you know how to prepare
something from scratch as opposed to
using a computer a design program and
these exams are administered you know in
the office you know with pen and paper
uh but when there people who work in the
you know who've had experience but
they're using some sort of computer
program that uh generates a lot of the
you know information a lot of the design
for them uh so you know we really need
to back up and make sure people have
those foundational skills uh and we are
outside of this effort working with the
community college system and the UN UNH
system to try and develop veloped like a
A
noncredit or non-degree program that
would support water professionals and do
Workforce Development not just for
septic system installers and designers
but uh other natural resource
professionals such as uh well
drillers um Wetland scientists surveyors
soil scientists and these are um skills
that we're going to need for the growing
State and uh they're very practical
skills and they're a good way to make a
living
and working in the state they jobs that
can't be sent offshore we think this is
a win-win and we'd like to continue on
that
effort for a followup um you had said
80% failure rate or did I get that wrong
correct 80% of the people on taking this
test do not pass
it yes and I I can say that you know in
preparing this letter I I wanted to say
a lot of people don't pass it but we
thought it was appropriate to say the
actual
number I
agree thank you Mr chair thank you Mr
chage for taking my question um what
type of feedback have you had from
people in the industry because they
would now have people working for them
that you know aren't
licensed uh think a good question uh you
know currently that that's kind of the
arrangement there is there's people who
who who do work under someone else's
license so this wouldn't be a a big
change um and I think it formalizes that
process and I think it uh would allow
for a bit more of a mentoring
environment Derby thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question just
very related to what representative rung
just asked um what types of um what
types of roles can unlce
um employee do for a designer somebody
that would be taking the designer um
test as opposed to somebody that would
be taking the installment test it's an
excellent question I'd like to defer
that question to representative makoni
because I think he's had uh direct
experience with
that anyone else for Mr
TR representative harp thank you Mr
chair thank you Mr trober was any
thought given to if somebody is required
to do all these studies under these
licensed supervisions that they could
automatically then get the license and
not have to take the test uh thank you
for that um question representative harb
uh we we had not considered that because
the because the statute requires the
exam you know um and so you know that's
a thing that we're needing to do so we'
need to change that um one thing that we
did think is that there um you know we
could add um you know right now we're
being quite explicit about one to two
years um there if there was interest
from the committee on more flexibility
uh there could be discussion of one to
two years or equivalent which might
allow for some combination of training
you know classes and training you know
that and that could be further spelled
out in in
rule follow follow up so you're not
opposed to something
that they could take the test earlier
maybe if it requires the
test this almost looks like if I have to
do two years with a designer I can't
take the test then I might be Albert
Einstein I could pass the test yeah and
I look at it like I think I'm hurting
the 20% people that that passed the test
right uh by this law because they're
going to say wait a minute I passed it
and now I wouldn't have been able to
pass it because I got to work for two
years right so I'm I'm just trying to
figure is there a way to mesh the two
together so those
20% don't get pushed out that's all it's
it's an excellent point and I think the
the idea of of you know introducing a
you know one year or equivalent or
twoyear or equivalent could satisfy that
because let's say you have someone who
has their professional engineering
license
or um you know work you know worked in
the um Construction Division of the
military or something like that you know
has you know some clear way of
demonstrating you know that they have
the background you know and that could
be fleshed out in rule good thank
you representative
Dy
um don't good question I don't have the
exact number but it's not a lot
sometimes it takes people two or three
times to
pass and I I don't I don't know exactly
the number but it's it is not um there
people are having trouble with this
because they not because they you know
uh well because they're really missing
some foundational knowledge and um we
have tried to be fair with this exam and
uh keep it consistent over time and that
um makes it hard for us to like go over
the test with them and say you know the
answer to this one is really you know
two because then it's you know uh it's
hard to keep that you know uh
confidential so that the information is
not used from the next exam so we try
and communicate the principles to them
but we're also not a you know we don't
have this capacity to to put a big
training program on so we will talk with
people we'll say these are the areas
where you're needing help we'll try to
explain those areas but it's
not getting you know it's not enough for
you know in some cases for them to to
you know get over the the
bar follow up how
many
um excellent question I do not know um
we haven't been keeping that demographic
information um I I you I don't want to
speculate but it is
um it you know it's it's tip actually I
don't want to speculate so I don't
know anyone else have any questions Rob
seeing
n seeing none thank you very much all
right thank you very much representive
mcon started ahead of
you we wanted to give you some
rest thank you I had an issue in my own
committee uh thank you for that what a
wonderful job commission there he um so
I'm I'm a practitioner I'm in the field
uh 30 years installer like 28 years as a
septic designer uh my formal business is
uh
excavation uh I have mentioned uh my two
sons in the
business uh when I started out wanting
to get into this business uh 30 years
ago uh there was one community college
class because I had no idea what soil
was other than digging it I probably
called it dirt like everybody else so I
seek out where where could I go take a
class to learn this in Community College
had a class that I traveled all the way
up to Berlin for um and then I figured
boy I knew everything and jumped into
the class and and failed
it um my sons um still both started out
in a college career I never wanted to be
part of the family business never wanted
to have employees equipment everything
else all came back to home and um we're
essentially tutored or trained by myself
in both trades I've also had a foreman
that's been with me 20 plus years who
oversees a lot of my site construction
as I'm going there's very little
opportunity to
learn um I have my license is uh number
1235 I believe my sons are in the 3000s
their licens number but with all those
people in the business only 150 or so
are actually active designers on the
installer side it it's it's it's a few
hundred and the the point of Aging out
is exactly what's happening whether
you're a carpenter or anything else so
when when they brought this to me um and
I forgot to mention how I gained my
background information be able to pick
up the Mel book and see what color it is
and to feel the texture of a sand and so
forth was from a 30 Old designer in town
who took a liking to me and showed me
what I needed came back in took the test
the next year and I passed so
um a lot of the Rush by young people
it's young people wanting to be
installers or designers especially
installers I can tell you from being in
the trades and having friends with 10
other companies in my area uh the kid
that comes to work for you that year and
learns how to used to be backos now it's
excavators so I get pretty handy and I
go out there and I lay out a system and
gez my boss ain't the smartest guy in
the world I should be able to do it
they're flooding the system they're all
coming in trying to take this test and
and I have so many people that will call
me and say to me representative how do I
get to the front of the line to take
this test and I keep being told by the
department that there are so many people
in the queue it's hard to get more
people in to take the test so I as a
practitioner um understand and we have
had a couple three people that um were
talented that have come to us and we're
sort of doing this sort of thing now at
least I have a couple people and and I
think there I know that there are
other men and women that are in this age
group group of me that want to work with
other people so I I I believe in what
they're trying to do and I I think it
will get more
people well we like to call them
licensed but permitted in the state and
uh if the department Can U work out or
this this committee can work out some
amendment I would I'd be in favor as a
practitioner I'm happy to answer any
questions representative Donald
thank you thank you for taking my
question um from the this to me sounds
very similar to an electrician type of
environment where you have Journeymen
and you have the this type of uh you
know training uh from your experience
what is the pay grade that you would get
that you may go through do you do you
have like different grades for payment
because you have someone who's been
licensed and trained what's the
incentive you do as a business owner for
someone to be doing designs and so forth
under me or yes and passing the
exam tell me again that's okay um what
is there an incentive for uh your
employees to say I would like to have
them you know pass the exam and just is
like just with like an electrician you
have a journeyman and then when they
pass they actually get an A bump up okay
in their pay is does that do you see
that in the industry do you see the same
type of environment this same type of
environment here with the septic design
and also with the installers where after
they pass the exam then there would get
and the incentive is they get a bump up
in pay grade okay I I think the
incentive is that um
these people that will Apprentice under
under our company or any other company
are going to learn to trade we're we're
going to get as an apprentice they're
going to be paid an hourly rate like a
laborer would be but we're we're going
to spend more time I fully anticipate
almost everyone that comes to us wanting
to do that is going to leave us and go
on their
own most most septic designers are
oneman bands unless you're working for
an engineering firm uh so and in are are
you know a couple people a l a lot of uh
a lot of the young installers that are
coming into the business I have a
son-in-law and some others um they've
worked for other companies uh they want
that permit in their hand and they go
out that helps you I would uh I I we pay
as far as I'm concerned a generous rate
for anyone that's working with us uh
whether you're conven we own convenience
store too but um they're they looking
for a path to get them forward when
they're coming to us and I don't see
them being with us 40 hours a week I see
that we have a job that comes into the
queue um we're going to go out onto the
site we're going to teach them how to
use survey equipment uh feel for the
land but they're only going to be with
us maybe 8 10 hours a week I would think
on a couple active jobs designers will
spend more time because then uh some
computer training but what what Mr
throwbridge brought up is so true when I
started in on this business everything
was hand drafting so you had you had
your folder out there and the pipes got
to be 50 feet and I got to scale it out
and I put it down and I look at it and I
have to put a 90 in which is a coupling
or or a a sweep tier whatever it is you
had this working knowledge because
you're drawing it the whole time now for
a couple thousand you buy a computer
program which is what the guys are doing
and all the information's already loaded
in there I'm going to do a stone and
pipe field and it draws everything for
you you almost have to work you have to
work people
backwards
okay
no representative Derby was next then
representative
M okay thank you Mr thank you for taking
my question um I'm sure I'm sure I'm um
I'm not totally understanding that it it
wouldn't be um obviously you're not
trying to get to to keep people employed
um longer by forcing them by having this
two this two-year period um you you
think that it would be a benefit to your
organization too um so can you just um I
just don't want to misinterpret the the
the last response to um representative
donal's question about um PE when when
you responded and said oh people would
leave as soon as they get this that
makes it sound like oh I don't want them
to leave so I'm gonna so you know I want
them to keep stay for two years so
what's the benefit to you for um for the
two-year um you know training period
well while they're with me I'm I'm
gaining um instead of um with a we're
two designers right now
uh instead of my being able to put out
three or four designs a week by having
someone there in training and getting
them up to speed I'll increase my
productivity and that's more income
coming in and I can pay more money out
uh I just I
don't this B so over 70% of all the SE
of all the property owners in our state
are on a private septic system um so
there's a need always of more designs
and more installs but I certainly don't
need 10 more people working for me
either so I see it as it's a
payforward and the engineering firms
would probably be more excited about it
because for them that would be a Growing
Experience for
them l representa l montain and
representative
Oran thank you for taking my questions
um just what I understand is your do you
have a separate company that does the
design and and a different company does
the install it's one company it's one
company we're a small family business my
daughter runs the office and four desks
like this and yeah we we do we are
licensed designers installers and septic
evaluators okay that's what we're we're
F we call ourselves a family septic
business I guess my my question though
when you said that if you have a sort of
an apprentice designer working through
this you you would only be able to use
them for 10 eight to 10 hours a
week they wouldn't be able to work
fulltime for you then unless they
perhaps were also involved in the
installing bu is that the idea well they
they could be they could be a laborer um
but I'm I'm just saying that uh they're
going to be gainfully employed but
they're they're going to need to do if
if they're only skill they're looking to
learn is to advance her knowledge on
septic design or install there's only so
many hours in a week we're doing that
work does that does that help you at all
um yes okay thank
you representative hgan for a
question thank you Mr chairman thanks
for taking my question I'm just curious
you're familiar with uh professional
organizations or retired professionals
that have gotten together in the form of
a group and offered training to
individuals
to get them up and coming have you
considered people in the in your field
uh other companies and people you're
acquainted with that have the same
Talent getting together and uh assisting
Dees in providing training that they're
unable to provide and sort of mentoring
people through a classroom or some other
program that help educate a larger
number of
individuals thank you for thank for the
question
that's that's big thinking that's a
that's a wonderful thought um I'm not
opposed to that um what happens many
times when
um Excavating
owners
um finish doing what they're doing uh
there's a most of them retire and go to
Florida or or as I as I say to my family
you'll find me either slumped over my
excavator or sitting at my desk so um
there's um because I just enjoy work and
and so many others do so it it's it's a
unique
profession so yes I I love the idea but
they'd have to give me one of those
white cars that they have for DS if
they anyone question anyone else
representative Ron thank thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question I'm curious what it what would
a starting pay be for a septic um
installer and a designer I'm just trying
to think of the incentive for someone to
go in the field like if they're working
for you but they're not licensed how you
know is is that going to be a big bump
up for
them um I think M throwbridge had
brought up the point on how much money
could a uh could a uh um homeowners save
by doing their own install and it's
thousands of
dollars um the septic design
um the septic design is no less than a
couple thousand dollars to something
more complicated to be
4500 and uh engineering firms charge
even more money than that there
there's someone that is good at their
trade it's um it's a fine trade to be
in for a followup Mr chair um so when I
when I look at the the section on septic
system installers and the section on
septic system designer if someone is you
know spending that year um you know
working with a a licensed installer does
that is there some Synergy there if they
wanted to be a designer like will they
learn kind of aspects of design at the
at the same time and vice
versa because they're not really I I I
guess my question is are they too really
segregated professions or are there
opportunities where the the skills and
knowledge overlap okay good point so um
when I first came into the industry
there were very few designer and also
permitted installers I I was
rare um and I think still the two
professions two Prof professions are are
separated by quite a bit but you can't
you can't truly be a good designer
unless you understand how the installs
going together there's there are so many
times I can hear it from installers that
they have um a company that will Design
things that you just can never build
they're not taking into they're not
taking into consideration slope and rise
and everything else so I I think I think
having the background in both U helps
not it doesn't help an installer so much
to know about the designer's business
but the designer that knows about how to
install a septic is is a much closer
person to passing that
test representative bail and
represent thank you Mr chair thank you
uh representative for taking my question
I just was looking at the bottom line on
the bill the the literal last line which
is the 60 days after it passage do you
think that's enough time um where I'm
coming from is that so this is we're
going to
have as representative harb
mentioned people who got licensed that
didn't do the two years all the way on
to um people who really really need to
do the whole entire two years is 60 days
to enact this this um legislation enough
time to make that transfer is my
question is that thank you
representative for the question it might
be better suited to u to the department
and whether rules need to be um to
address that issue but as we all know
let's say this thing flies through the
house goes to the Senate the governor
isn't going to turn it out
till June or later uh which brings them
into the next cycle people have already
taken the next spring test um I I
foresee that anybody that passes the
test um up until that time does isn't
required to do any additional
apprenticing and so forth but I would
leave it to the department to uh
consider rules and I'm not one that that
will say to the Department of
Environmental Services say I want you to
write rules but I'm I'm going to tell
you and the chairman will know this I
have I have full faith and trust in in
this Branch subsurface to do the right
thing I really
do representative
Simpson thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
and I probably should have asked this to
Mr trobridge earlier so apologies but I
was just trying to fit together the um
how this will work in my brain and just
wondered if um is there a way that uh
the connections like a easy way that the
connections will be made with folks who
want to enter the field and those of you
who are working in this design and
install business um will the department
be able to refer will have a list and
kind of refer people to to um
practitioners in the field who are
interested you know when they sign up
for the test or I just wondered if you
could talk a minute about that yeah if
if I understand the question so there is
a Statewide organization it's had a name
change used to be the granted State
installers and designers uh very well
membershi uh there's there's a a name
difference
now so there's a resource and they're
they're doing uh they're doing training
for uh septic evaluators also the
website anyone that goes to Department
envirment
Services a subsurface brings you right
on to a a great website uh that's then
you click on uh designs construction
approvals or whatever and there complete
listing of all the people that have
current permits and licenses permits for
designs and installs uh all show up
there so I have faith that they that the
department could make that connection
there there is tremendous frustration by
the people that take the test and fail
tremendous and I I live in a small town
I own a convenience store everyone knows
one contractor for another and how can I
get there they're frustrated and I until
I heard the department say you know we
can't say you got you know question a
wrong you know I I understand that
reason so I I think they're trying to
get people to yes to be able to get a
permit anyone else for
questions seeing none thank you very
much yes I think
you I think we are
right uh
seeing well we we are done uh do we want
to talk about uh which one
uh was it was it 141 141
141 uh question is do we want to
uh do we want to
execute we feel do we feel we can
executive go into executive session and
just do
it uh well yeah so actually the the
decision is mine and representative
veils but we we I I like to
consult but I think we have enough
people
yeah no but you you're here you you just
absorb it let's
go for and abstain yeah you can't
abstain can't no uh yeah yeah but I can
just ignore him we can we can we can
skip over if that's makes you feel well
or you can go sit in the
audience Ahad all right uh
I'll I'll open the executive session on
well House Bill
1141 11 11 11 excuse me
11:41 been a long day I open this open
the session and I'll accept the
motion on House Bill 141 representative
R okay volunteering
again I on
1141 do I hear a second a second second
by representative Vale wish to speak on
the I think NH um made good argument for
changing current statute so that we can
account for um any change in
use I think it's
everyone to
go
it's
still proceed without reing micr just a
little Lou how's mine mine sounds mine
sounds fine how uh
here yep
nope do I how's
mine
um microphone
issues is it better yes it is could be
better we did a reset thank
you okay um I'll speak to my motion of
ought to pass
uh for House Bill
1141 um I believe this bill is important
because it accounts for a change in use
um when determining whether a septic
system needs to um have a a change in
its loading capacity I believe Mr
trobridge made a good case for that um
and also went into more about if the lot
is 5 Acres more in size and is served by
a se's Disposal system system that
received construction and operational
approval from the department so I I just
feel like it's um going to be uh a
nice a way of better ensuring that
septic systems can handle their capacity
that's coming from the dwelling and
safeguarding the groundwater because of
it thank you you uh representative veale
for any wish do you wish to speak on
your
second
um I believe representative rang spoke
most of the things I would have
mentioned thank
you anyone else wish to speak on the
motion seeing none will the clerk please
call a rooll on a to
pass ought to pass on
11:41 representative har
yes he's not
here
representative
Healey
yes representative
wolf
yes representative Donnelly
yes clerk quotes
yes representative Vil yes
representative rung yes
oop representative Horan yes my
apologies represent Simpson
yes representative
Derby
yes representative L montin
yes that should be it that's everything
everybody gotta call the oh um
chairman sorry one two
three seven n is anyone not voted who
wishes to
vote has anyone not voted wishes to vote
seeing none what what does it one two
three
four 10 12 12 nothing 12 12 to nothing
motion
passes consent consent yes that's it I
call the uh executive session
closed and the meeting's
closed
Lista Mr chair I have a question on the
last bill we discussed apparently DS has
requested an amendment to take into
account Ru making just um in respect for
representative Wolf's comment earlier
about amendments um is there someone
who's going to be drafting that
amendment to make sure we have it ready
and plenty of time for the exec
session that's right is uh will uh Dees
be submitting a an amendment that
someone someone could put together could
please put their name
on
yes okay that that would that would be
fine okay
thanks okay thank
you